كون Tensai TV على الإطلاق آنا
[موسيقى]
لهذا السبب
مقدمة
[موسيقى]
في محطات مؤلمة في جميع أنحاء اليابان
ريدر لسبعة وضعيات ديزني حصص الفاكهة
محطة
npo nun Tokkyu Oh Mecha Riders
Pub e 4 ab Sat girls دعونا نركب تشكل كوبر 3 الآن
موكاي
أنا Stop Mukai. منتج موسيقى وملحن لحن قطار.
قم بإنشاء أكثر من 110 محطة بلحن المغادرة فقط ، وإذا قمت بوضع ذلك ، قم بعمل أكثر من 200 علامة تبويب
أظن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لعبت كلاعب لوحة مفاتيح في فرقة تسمى Cassiopeia لمدة 35 عامًا.
إنه مُركب وهو أيضًا لوحة مفاتيح ، لذا فهو مثل هذا.
اذهب هذا الطبيب 9 ​​أ
لقد كان أداءً صعبًا للغاية
تتناغم على الويب
همم
سلاسل nsr المنشور الفتحة المستخدم
عمل حارس تظاهر خرز المشهد yso
[موسيقى]
وو ، بالطبع ، الصوت الذي يسهل سماعه مهم.
أليست هي لحن قطار؟
إذا كنت شديد الغرابة ، فستكون أذنيك تحت عينيك في المرة القادمة.
حتى لو حاولت ركله بهدوء ، فهو في حالتي دماغ على شكل جرس
[موسيقى]
همم
أعتقد أنني حصلت على معظم الوقت
إذا كان دور ذلك الطفل ، على سبيل المثال ، سيأتي القطار على هذا النحو ، أو الكارب.
أتذكر معظم الوقت ، لذلك أجعل الأمر كما لو أنني سأحصل على عمل في قطار شاهق.
يا
[موسيقى]
على مترو أنفاق Tozai Line Tokyo Meter ، انعكس كل الطريق بين المحطات الأولى والأخيرة على خط Tozai.
يبدو أنها أصبحت محطة واحدة عندما أسمع ذلك
[موسيقى]
كانت هناك منطقة في طوكيو في الأيام الخوالي.
ضع أداة في هذا قليلا
في المرة التالية التي أراد فيها الطالب أن يراها كانت مسرحية موسيقية صغيرة لجيل الشباب.
أن تتحول إلى التفكير
هذا هو Bailey Secret الشفاف ، على الرغم من أن ملف
يوم العاطفة بطاقة التوربينات ماج الصداع
الفودو أبولي ويوم رايلفان
ليس لشرف كبير لي أن ألحن لحن القطار.
من الصحيح حقًا أن صوتي يُسمع على خط السكة الحديد المفضل لدي
لم أكن أبدا سعيدا جدا
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم نعم